[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und claus kleber
guten abend heute war eine politische
entscheidung fällig in sachen corona
bekämpfung bund und land mussten
föderales durcheinander vermeiden in
einer grundsatzfrage und die heißt was
ist wichtiger fairness oder corona
bekämpfung natürlich wird es auf dauer
unfair dass geimpfte menschen mit
bezahlen wenn andere sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen und in quarantäne müssen
für die lohnausfälle hat die
allgemeinheit mittlerweile eine halbe
milliarde euro lohn ausfälle ersetzt und
irgendwann soll damit schluss sein
einerseits andererseits kann genau diese
maßnahme den kampf gegen korona
schwieriger machen weil leute dann ja
vielleicht keine lust mehr haben sich
mit einem test und quarantäne den
arbeitslohn abzuschneiden und dann
lassen sie die vorsichtsmaßnahmen bieber
tun so als wäre nichts also was ist
wichtiger fairness oder corona
bekämpfung
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
entschieden heute fairness ist wichtiger
am ersten november ist für
impfverweigerer schluss mit
lohnfortzahlung in quarantäne fall eines
trams berichtet für sie hier bei diesem
maschinenbauunternehmen in baden
württemberg gilt bereits was spätestens
ab november für alle bundesländer
greifen wird es gibt keinen anspruch auf
lohnfortzahlung wenn man als ungeimpft
ein quarantäne muss für das unternehmen
ein unding wir als unternehmen glauben
daran dass das instant hilft die
pandemie zu bekämpfen aber dass die
politik jetzt versucht durch die
hintertür unternehmen die menschen zu
zwingen sich impfen zu lassen halten wir
nicht für den richtigen weg baden
württemberg und andere länder waren
vorgeprescht nun einigten sich die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
auf eine einheitliche linie kein geld
mehr für ungeimpfte in quarantäne
das auch eine frage von fairness jenigen
die sich und andere durch eine impfung
schützen
haben wir dann auch die berechtigte
frage warum eigentlich für jemanden der
im urlaub war ein risikogebiet und
leider nicht geimpft ist der dann in
quarantäne muss warum sie dann für so
jemand mit zahlen die regelung wird aldi
betreffen für die es eine impfempfehlung
gibt die sich aber nicht impfen lassen
wollen müssen sie hier in quarantäne
nach einem kontakt mit einem infizierten
oder nach einer reise in ein
risikogebiet dann sollen sie keine
lohnfortzahlung mehr erhalten es gibt
aber ausnahmen wenn ich mich nicht
impfen lassen kann wenn es eine
medizinische indikation gibt aus warum
das nicht möglich ist dann kann dies
durch attest dargelegt werden eine
genaue diagnose muss in dem attest nicht
sein sondern das kann dann immer test
einfach so erfolgen wichtig ist nochmal
wer krank ist erhält natürlich weiterhin
eine lohnfortzahlung die parteien der
kanzlerkandidaten bewerten die regelung
ungewohnt einhellig fast durchgängig
positiv dass freiheitsrechte
eingeschränkt würden sagt dagegen
fdp-chef lindner im heute-journal update
die wahlfreiheit wäre gefährdet wir sind
der staat des grundgesetzes hier gilt
selbstbestimmung es gibt keine
gesetzliche impfpflicht also sollte man
auch kein impliziten unausgesprochenen
impfzwang auf den weg bringen kritiker
wie gesundheitsexperte lauterbach von
der spd warnt vor dem risiko einer
verdeckten pandemie hoffe das kommt
nicht so wie ich es befürchtet
es kann aber durchaus so sein dass hier
ein teil der pandemie in den also
untergrund gerät was sich die leute
nicht mehr melden die in die quarantäne
müssen oder nicht mehr sich registrieren
beispielsweise werden sie in die lokale
gehen die gewerkschaften lehnen den
beschluss ab schließlich erführe der
arbeitgeber so wer geimpft sei und wer
nicht eine abfrage des impfstatus ist in
den meisten branchen nicht erlaubt hier
entstehen neue konflikte in quarantäne
fall muss dann der arbeitgeber die den
nachweis erhalten warum eine kern zähne
angeordnet wurde und das gibt dann
rückschlüsse auf die gesundheitliche
verfassung der beschäftigten und das ist
genau das was wir nicht wollen das
maschinenbauunternehmen in baden
württemberg will weiter zahlen für seine
ungeübten mitarbeiter in quarantäne weil
dann wohl ohne staatliche zuschüsse doch
der kurs den die politik einschlägt ist
klar der druck auf ungeimpfte nimmt zu
am ende des tages wird christian lindner
im journal update sein und befragt
werden nicht nur zu corona 00 35
letzten samstag hat jemand an einer
tankstelle in idar oberstein einen
jungen studentin umgebracht bei der ihn
gebeten hatte eine schutzmaske
anzuziehen man kann dieses furchtbare
verbrechen jetzt nicht einfach der
irrlichternden vielfalt aus corona
leugnern impfgegnern skeptikern
ängstlichen nachdenklichen und wütenden
sozial solidaritäts verweigerern
zuschustern
das darf man nicht man kann aber auch
nicht die augen davor verschließen dass
es in dieser vielfalt keine deutliche
abgrenzung gibt nicht mal gegen extreme
gewalt nicht wenige bejubelten den
abschreckenden effekt den der mord haben
wird gegen weitere einschränkungen und
schutzmaßnahmen wie radikal ist diese
szene geworden fragt dominik lässt
meister
es ist eine tat die idar oberstein ja
das ganze land erschüttert der tod des
20-jährigen studentin alex
erschossen in dieser tankstelle von
einem masten verweigerer die
bundesregierung verurteilt
diese gezielte tötung auf das schärfste
die enthemmung von gewalt macht
sprachlos wir trauern um den jungen mann
der niederträchtig erschossen wurde es
ist samstagabend als ein mann die
tankstelle betritt um bier zu kaufen der
kassierer weist ihn auf die masken
pflicht hin der 49 jährige verlässt die
tankstelle und kommt kurze zeit später
zurück und erschießt den 20 jährigen in
seiner vernehmung gab er an so die
polizei dass er die korona maßnahmen
ablehnen
wir sehen bereits jetzt dass dieser
schreckliche wort
instrumentalisiert wird
das beobachten wir natürlich ganz genau
denn das internet ist kein rechtsfreier
raum wir sehen dass es eine
protestbewegung gegen die staatlichen
beschränkung maßnahmen aus dem bereich
der korona lugner und im lager der
sogenannten querdenker gibt nach zdf
informationen
veröffentlichte der mutmaßliche täter
bereits 2009 10 auf twitter drohungen
sein letzter post lautete meine muskeln
sind gespannt mein geist geschärft gnade
denen welche diese situation
heraufbeschworen haben dies liefert
hinweise auf seine gesinnung der
sprecher des bundesinnenministeriums
verweist auf laufende ermittlungen
nach allen erkenntnissen die wir bisher
haben handelt es sich um einen
einzelfall um einen zwei extremen
einzelfall leben aber eben doch um einen
einzelfall von dem wir nun keine
generalisierende rückschlüsse ziehen
können der täter von idar oberstein mag
einzeltäter gewesen sein doch er
sympathisierte netz mit zum teil
radikalen gruppen die behörden sehen
hier eine wachsende radikalisierung
im messenger dienst telegramm zeigen
einige verständnis so heißt es es muss
endlich mal etwas passieren diese masken
scheiße ist eine absolute tyrannei das
muss man mit waffengewalt regeln diese
tat zeigt es ist im umfeld von corona
protesten von verschwörungstheorien
geschehen der täter gibt ja an diese tat
auch für das land oder für seine idee
vom volk vollzogen zu haben und das
reiht sich ein eigentlich in einer
ganzen serie von solchen anschlägen die
wir in der radikalisierung extremismus
forschung beobachten die stimmung in der
gesellschaft ist aggressiver geworden
der mord von idar oberstein zeigt dass
hass tödlich sein kann
das ist so viel wir bisher wissen die
tat eines einzelnen verbrechers aber es
gibt da schon auch eine extreme
grundströmung auf der solche einzelfälle
möglich werden prozesse am extremen rand
mit denen sich der soziologe professor
matthias quendt an der hochschule
magdeburg-stendal befasst guten namen
dorthin braut sich etwas zusammen
da braut sich etwas zusammen nicht erst
seit dem wochenende auch nicht dass seit
dem vergangenen monaten nicht mal erst
seit der korona pandemie das war ja in
dem beitrag gerade zu sehen der
mutmaßliche und die auch geständige
täter der war schon radikal politisch
den extremen der extremen rechten
zugeneigt bevor es corona überhaupt gab
das heißt also die tweets wie hier
berichtet wurden die sind aus dem jahr
2009 10 schon da war der hier als täter
gelten personen in diesen kanälen
unterwegs hat sich radikal als
klimaleugner als ein anhänger von
untergangsszenarien
dargestellt präsentiert hat vor allem
kanäle der radikalen rechten gefolgt und
das scheint sich im kontext einer
allgemeinen radikalisierung im diffusen
das spektrum der maßnahme gegner in den
vergangenen monaten und jahren
zugespitzt zu haben und wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen so extrem dieser fall
war sind angriffe auf personen die dafür
zuständig sind das pflichten eingehalten
werden das maßnahme eingefallen
eingehalten werden leider wirklich kein
einzufangen was ist denn in einer
gesellschaft die wirkung einer solchen
tat zumal dann wenn es mehrere gibt auf
einer ganzen skala von demonstrationen
wo polizisten mit gewalt angegangen
werden bis zu diesem unvergleichlichen
verbrechen
die wirkung ist einschüchterung die
wirkung ist verunsicherung die wirkung
ist aber auch an das eigene radikale
radikalisierte milieu eine bestärkung
und ein aufruf demnach zu folgen die
situation eskalieren zu lassen bis hin
zu einem bürgerkrieg den sich ja auch im
spektrum der sogenannten neuen rechten
der eine oder andere in der
vergangenheit auch schon öffentlich
gewünscht hat das heißt es geht hier um
eine politische dimension damit hat es
auch die qualität eines terroristischen
aktes denn die menschen die im alltag
dafür einstehen dass regeln eingehalten
werden die den laden am laufen halten an
tankstellen aber auch in schulen
öffentlichen nahverkehr und so weiter
die immer wieder angegriffen werden auf
verschiedene art und weise oft eben auch
körperlich und aggressiv die sind jetzt
in der situation dass sie unterstützung
brauchen dass sie zuspruch brauchen um
eben nicht zu resignieren und sich das
nächste mal zu fragen na ja vielleicht
interveniere ich lieber nicht wenn
jemand keine maske trägt sich nicht an
die regeln hält und letztlich damit ja
auch die den zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft und in der bekämpfung der
pandemie insgesamt gefährdet es ist ja
schon ein bisschen so nach so einer tat
dass man sich einen innerlichen ruck
geben muss in zukunft in irgend einem
kiosk oder in der tankstelle zu sagen
bitte sehr abstand bitte und ändern sich
an die maske das war eine reine
selbstverständlichkeit dass höflich mal
zu sagen das hat sich geändert seit dem
wochenende ist dass der gewünschte
effekt hat das ist der gewünschte effekt
es wird ja auch jetzt im wahlkampf für
damit plakatiert die masken abzulegen es
wird auch im politischen spektrum dazu
aufgerufen sich nicht impfen zu lassen
auf masken zu verzichten eine art
widerstand und sei er nur durch durch
ungehorsam zu leisten gegen die
maßnahmen und solche akte der
einstellung das ist ja alles
demokratisch legitimiert also es ist das
selbstverständlich kann ich aufrufen und
sagen leute lasst die im verein
natürlich aber auch damit setze ich den
anderen teil der gesellschaft und auch
diejenigen die auf zusammenhalt auf
problemlösung setzen unter druck und
bestärke auch native die auf eine andere
art und weise und mit einem
undemokratischen hintergrund diese
negative dann radikalisieren die zu
steigern das ist ja das entscheidende
wir haben es hier nicht mit einem
extremismus von irgendwelchen
kleingruppen am rande zu tun sondern von
einer steigerung gesellschaftlicher
konflikte hin zu radikalen extrem
auswirkungen und deswegen kann man das
auch nicht bloß getrennt voneinander
behandelt auch wenn man das natürlich
differenzieren muss es jetzt angesichts
dieses mordes natürlich schwierig zu
sagen aber überschätzt man nicht
vielleicht die größe dieser
gewaltbereiten gruppe in zeiten in denen
es noch keine social media gab da haben
solche leute irgendwas mit filz schiff
dann die klo wände geschrieben und
niemand hat darauf geachtet heute
erscheint das dann glänzend präsentiert
auf irgendwelchen internetseiten und
semiprofessionelle aus oder sogar voll
professionell dann neigt man leicht dazu
die zu denken das ist eine ganze
gesellschaftliche strömung vielleicht
ist es ja doch eine kleine radikale
randgruppe ohne chance vielleicht hätte
sie aber gut getan auch schon früher bei
den groß schreiben mal hinzuhören was
ist da eigentlich schief gelaufen oder
wo es sind die ursachen für solche form
der der einer antinationalen
radikalisierung das bedeutet ja es gibt
auch den gewünschten effekt sich größer
zu machen sich als stärker zu
produzieren als man es in wirklichkeit
ist andererseits aber ist das sichtbar
werden von von von radikalisierung
strömen über soziale netzwerke im
internet ja doch zumindest eine eine
sensorik um darauf aufmerksam zu werden
und dann ist der große unterschied
natürlich die auswirkungen die es haben
kann wenn nur ein einzelner von den
vielen tausenden die aufrufe zur gewalt
beispielsweise auch telegramm lesen das
für bare münze nimmt und dann siegt sagt
ich gehe jetzt wirklich los und lasse
den den worten taten folgen die
aufmerksamkeit ist groß und die milieus
die sich hier zusammentreffen sind auch
innen sich viel ideologisch viel
homogener sind eher bereit sich immer
weiter ins noch radikalere zu steigen
das ist auf einer
willkürlichen toilette sozusagen
eine ganz andere aufmerksamkeit eine
ganz andere öffentlichkeit konstruktion
die einschätzung des fachmannes
dankeschön professor kennt und einen
guten abend
hier geht es nun weiter mit nachrichten
von heinz wolf bundeskanzlerin merkel
und verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer haben den einsatz der
bundeswehr bei der evakuierungs mission
in afghanistan gewürdigt die soldatinnen
und soldaten hätten unter schwierigsten
umständen und großer gefahr
unglaubliches geleistet sagte kramp
karrenbauer
bei einem rückkehr appell im
niedersächsischen seedorf wurden
stellvertretend einige von ihnen mit der
einsatzmedaille ausgezeichnet kam kein
bauer verteidigte dabei nochmals den
afghanistan einsatz der bundeswehr
zugleich müsse aber offen und ehrlich
bilanz gezogen werden
nach den diplomatischen verwerfungen um
einen neuen indopazifik sicherheitspakt
und ein geplatztes u boot geschäft gibt
es entspannungssignale frankreichs
präsident makro und us-präsident beiden
haben heute telefoniert und wollen sich
wie es anschließend hieß im kommenden
monat persönlich treffen der nach hause
beordert der französische botschafter
soll nächste woche nach washington
zurückkehren
im kampf gegen die korona pandemie
wollen die usa weitere 500 millionen
impfdosen für ärmere länder zur
verfügung stellen das verkündete
us-präsident beiden bei einer video
konferenz am rande der un-generaldebatte
beiden schwor die staats und
regierungschefs dabei auf ein
gemeinsames ziel ein bis september 2022
sollen in jedem land 70 prozent der
bevölkerung gegen das corona virus
immunisiert sein
die weltgesundheitsorganisation
empfiehlt jetzt deutlich striktere
grenzwerte für schadstoffe in der luft
als bisher in einer heute
veröffentlichten neuen ausgabe der
richtlinien heißt es gesundheitliche
folgen treten schon bei wesentlichen
niedrigeren schadstoffkonzentrationen
auf als zuvor angenommen jährlich sieben
millionen menschen sterben nach who
schätzungen infolge von
luftverschmutzung weltweit am stärksten
betroffen seien die menschen in ländern
mit niedrigem und mittlerem einkommen
china als großer finanzierer von
kohlekraftwerk im ausland hat einen
kurswechsel angekündigt präsident eugene
king sagte in einer videobotschaft für
die un-vollversammlung china werde
andere entwicklungsländer bei der
entwicklung grüner und kohlenstoffarme
energien stärker unterstützen und keine
neuen kohlekraftwerke im ausland bauen
für die energiepolitik im eigenen land
hat die chinesische regierung
angekündigt vor 2030 die co2-emissionen
zu reduzieren
in der ukraine ist ein enger berater von
präsident zellen ski offenbar ziel eines
mordanschlags geworden der mann blieb
dabei unversehrt eine weitere person
allerdings wurde schwer verletzt bei dem
vorfall nahe der hauptstadt hier wurden
mehr als zehn kugeln auf das auto des
beraters abgefeuert die ermittler gehen
von einem politischen tatmotiv aus der
anschlag sei womöglich zur die
stabilisierung der politischen lage im
land verübt worden
sonntag ist wahl und ein ergebnis steht
schon vor dem sonntag ziemlich fest die
kanzlerin wird gehen auch aus mangel an
konkurrenz gilt sie schon seit jahren
als die starke frau europas wer danach
kommt wird wohl erstens er keine frau
und zweitens weniger stark sein das
zweite kann sich im lauf der zeit
bessern so ist deutschland zwar ein
europäisches thema es gibt keinen
besseren ort europäische einschätzungen
dazu zu sammeln als brüssel unsere
korrespondenten dort ist angelegt
mutter fini jetzt ist schluss mit titel
die französische zeitung liberation und
widmet den deutschen wahlen und der
kanzlerin eine ganze ausgabe es müssen
über 100 eu gipfel sein die merkel
durchgehalten durchverhandelt
durchlitten hat sie hat die eu zusammen
oder auch aufgehalten je nach standpunkt
aber ihr abgang da ist sich europa einig
hinterlässt eine lücke
es gibt diesen tisch in europa und da
war merkel diejenige um die sich alle
herum gruppen
müssen alle anderen eine neue position
finden und das ist etwas was der
niederländischen regierung sorge macht
die kommen
mark rutte der niederländer hat sich
gerade zum anführer der sogenannten
sparsamen regierungschefs hochgearbeitet
vier tage im juli 2020 versuchte er den
corona hilfsfonds möglichst klein zu
verhandeln zusammen mit österreich und
skandinavien
haushaltsdisziplin keine gemeinsamen
schulden das war bis zur pandemie auch
deutsche politik jetzt gibt es in den
haag hoffnung auf eine rückkehr zum
alten sparkurs durch politischen die
meisten niederländischen politiker sehen
laschet und scholz als sichere bank muss
es berbalk kennen sie einfach weniger
auch die franzosen lieben merkel und
verstehen es selbst nicht denn sie ließ
präsident marco mit seinen europäischen
initiativen auflaufen gilt in paris als
visionslos und unentschlossen stadt
hochfliegende pläne rechnet man auch bei
den nachfolgern mit eher kleinen
schritten
im moment sehen wir bei keinem der drei
kandidaten das kaliber eines helmut kohl
frankreich führt die südeuropäischen
länder an die froh sind über den durch
gemeinsame schulden finanzierten corona
v und ihn am liebsten als
dauereinrichtung hätten deshalb
sympathisiert frankreich mit rot grün
eine regierung die mit macht bei mehr
europa und mehr schulden alles nur keine
neue sparpolitik
ein fdp finanzminister wäre wolfgang
schäuble hoch zehn
das würde eine große krise für europa
bedeuten für die polin ist
haushaltspolitik er kein thema die
polnische regierung wünscht sich einen
christdemokraten einen der vorhersehbar
ist sowie merkel eben rot grün sehen sie
kritisch sie fürchten mehr ärger bei
rechtsstaatlichkeit und klima
es gibt ängste dass die neue deutsche
regierung beim klima ehrgeiziger sein
könnte als die alte aber polen setzt auf
pragmatismus und die deutsche industrie
die bremsen wird
europa guckt an diesem wochenende nach
deutschland mit hoffnung und ein
bisschen furcht vor der ungewissheit und
der lücke die angela merkel hinterlässt
mit zusätzlichen milliarden will die
bundesregierung beim klimaschutz im
gebäudebereich
nachbessern das kabinett dazu ein
maßnahmenprogramm von wirtschafts- und
innenministerium beschlossen weil die
halle wie wird die förderung angenommen
wie groß ist die nachfrage
nimmt fahrt auf deswegen wird der
fördertopf ja auch noch mal aufgestockt
aber unterm strich ist die
sanierungsrate laut klimaforschern in
deutschland immer noch viel zu niedrig
und tatsächlich sind gebäude ein
wichtiger faktor beim klimaschutz fast
ein drittel der gesamten co2 emissionen
verursachen sie laut umweltbundesamt
vergangenes jahr hat der gebäudesektor
als einziger bereich sein klimaziel
nicht erreicht darum muss die
bundesregierung nun nachbessern punkt
weitere 5,7 milliarden euro in die
häuser sanierung geld für den austausch
von fenstern und türen die dämmung von
außenwänden und dächern oder
biomasseheizungen und wärmepumpen
geld allein wird es nicht richten auch
die standards für den neubau sollen
angehoben werden die festzulegen darum
muss sich die neue bundesregierung
kümmern kritik zur heutigen meldung kam
von umweltverbänden sie kritisieren die
bundesregierung habe den gebäudesektor
jahrelang vernachlässigt und fordern
unter anderem klare zeitvorgaben bei der
gebäudesanierung
noch ein blick auf den dax der konnte
sich von seinen verlusten zu
wochenanfang wieder erholen 1 prozent
plus neuigkeiten gibt es von der
amerikanischen notenbank sie erwartet
nicht mehr ganz so starkes wachstum
dieses jahr dafür eine höhere inflation
von über vier prozent in den usa die
zinsen bleiben auf null niveau die fed
fast aber eine erhöhung kommendes jahr
ins auge deutlich früher als bisher
angenommen weil er gerade auf vielen
dank
zum start des jährlichen extremwetter
kongresses in hamburg haben führende
wissenschaftler vor der steigenden co2
konzentration in der atmosphäre gewarnt
die experten forderten zugleich einen
gesellschaftlichen dialog über den
klimawandel der etwaige ängste nicht
verstärkt der deutsche wetterdienst
stellte im zuge des kongresses seien
fakten papier vor wonach die menge der
niederschläge beim hochwasser im juli
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit ohne
klimawandel deutlich geringer
ausgefallen wäre
weil der straßenrad-wm in flandern hat
die deutsche mixed-staffel um routinier
tony martin die goldmedaille gewonnen
zweiter nach 44 eineinhalb kilometer
wurden die niederlande vor italien für
martin war es das letzte profirennen
seiner karriere zuvor hatte er
angekündigt nach der wm seine laufbahn
zu beenden
es ist die zweite medaille für den bund
deutscher radfahrer bei den laufenden
titelkämpfen
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
35 13 21
22 31 superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
das pracht schloss der hohenzollern
mitten in berlin wieder aufzubauen war
ein heftig umstrittenes projekt zwischen
bürger-engagement
politischen winkelzügen historischen und
manchmal auch aktuell im größenwahn aber
jetzt ist es da heute einen weiteren
schritt eröffnet und wahrscheinlich
werden die um die frauenkirche in
dresden die zweifel allmählich verwelken
viel kleiner hätte der bau auch nicht
ausfallen dürfen wenn man sieht was für
ein spagat darin platz finden muss vom
stolz auf großartige sammlungen aus
allen kulturen und kritische
auseinandersetzung damit wie sie
überhaupt dorthin gekommen sind manches
ist jetzt ins schloss gezogen um nicht
lange zu bleiben alles andere wäre
verlogen stephan merseburger berichtet
einige räume sind spektakulär geraten
wie der von architekt wang shu der sich
der chinesischen hof kunst widmet oder
der kuppelraum in dem wandmalereien aus
buddhistischen tempeln zu bestaunen sind
ein weiteres glanzstück an dem
allerdings blut klebt ist dass luft aus
dem heutigen papua neuguinea wo die
deutschen kolonialherren grausam wüteten
die informationen der ausstellungsmacher
dazu sind eher spärlich
die sammlungen aus der zeit des
kolonialismus sind hoch umstritten
objekte wurden gekauft und getauscht
aber auch geraubt geplündert und
erpresst der bundespräsident heute zu
besuch im humboldt-forum redet der
nation ins gewissen sich endlich mit der
deutschen kolonialgeschichte zu befassen
in unserem kollektiven gedächtnis
ist die deutsche kolonialzeit entweder
glorifiziert worden oder aber noch
häufiger gänzlich vergessen würden
vielleicht wollten wir lieber gar nicht
allzu genau wissen an
welchen dieser weit entfernten ort
natürlich auch deutsche als
kolonialherren menschen unterdrückt
ausgebeutet beraubt und umgebracht haben
hier objekte aus der ehemaligen kolonie
kamerun wie dieser prächtige thron
angeblich ein geschenk in diesem raum
wird versucht das bewusstsein für die
historie zu schärfen kolonialismus
spielerisch erklärt für kinder etwa über
deutschlands kinder spricht auch die
nigerianische schriftstellerin team
amanda
gucci dieses coaching erfahren
schulkinder etwas von namibia das
ehemalige deutsch südwestafrika
wissen sie dass hunderttausend herero
von den deutschen umgebracht wurden
wissen sie von den vergifteten brunnen
wissen sie von den sex sklavinnen und
den anderen sklaven im deutschen lager
camps sind ja schimming modeschöpferin
aus namibia wurde nach berlin eingeladen
sie hat ein kunstwerk für das humboldt
forum geschaffen ein kleid dessen
schleppe fotos zeigt die sie in den
museumsdepots entdeckt hat sie erinnern
an den grausamen völkermord den die
deutschen vor mehr als 100 jahren an
herero und nama begangen haben
für uns ist wichtig dass menschen
vertreter der herkunftskultur in
ursprungsländer hier auch ihre aussage
platzieren können
dialog auf augenhöhe rückgaben debatten
über kolonialismus die erwartungen an
das forum mit der historisierenden
preußen fassade sind riesig
es gibt bei uns weiter mit einem blick
in die große welt der niemandem etwas
wegnimmt nur etwas gibt erweiterten
horizont das auslandsjournal unter
anderem mit einer reportage von katrin
eigendorf allein unter taliban reise
durch ein erschüttertes land für solche
berichte hat kathrin dieses jahr den
hanns joachim friedrichs preis gewonnen
bleiben sie einfach dran und unser
heute-journal update gibt es dann wie
schon gesagt 0 35 mit wulf schmiese des
nordens
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute ist herbst
beginnen und wir schauen auf den
meteorologischen sommer zurück und der
war ja deutschlandweit zu warm aber die
temperaturen sehr unterschiedlich
verteilt nach norden deutlich wärmer und
im süden sogar kälter und er war zu nass
und wenn sie ganz in den westen schauen
westlich des rheins dieser blaue fleck
das spiegelt hier teilweise die
flutkatastrophe wieder wo riesige
regenmengen zusammen kam und vor solchen
extremereignissen
warnen meteorologen ja schon seit jahren
und der weltklimarat der hat es auch
bestätigt dass diese
extremwetterereignisse weltweit zu
nehmen und zu nehmen werden im zuge der
weltweiten klimaerwärmung schauen auf
die nachts im norden werden viele worten
dabei sein und der wind legt schon mal
zu im süden bildet sich in gewässernähe
nebel ganz nach süden hin klart es auf
und die sterne zeigen sich bei
temperaturen dort bis 3 grad es wird
kalt sonst deutlich milder vor allem an
der nordsee mit 14 grad morgen dann im
tagesverlauf zidan sturmtief richtung
ostsee und dann richtung südosten weiter
es gibt regen und viel wind sturmböen an
der ostsee aber auch in der nordsee
möglich ganz oben süden da scheint
verbreitet die sonne temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von 23 grad
richtung oberrhein und 16 grad an der
ostsee die nächsten tage werden wärmer
am freitag bis 23 grad samstag bis 24
und sonntag 26 grad aber dann kommen
gewitter auf und damit ein schöner abend